[Music]
what is an algorithm an algorithm is
just a method for
solving some problem right and kind of
the
the design space for creating algorithms
is huge
um so you know you have to be creative
in
finding something that works and works
well i enjoy that and i also enjoy once
i understand how to solve a problem
implementing an algorithm and seeing it
run fast on my laptop i enjoy watching
that too
a lot of the algorithms i work on i
develop are albums for very large data
sets data sets that are so large that
maybe you can't fit them in your memory
or you at least can't fit them in your
fast memory
i work on algorithms that kind of
compress the data so that
you don't store everything but you store
a very tiny amount but you can still
answer interesting queries about the
data so these are called sketching
algorithms
and let's say that i am a big company
like facebook okay and tons of people
are visiting my webpage every day
there's a stream of data that's coming
in let's say the stream of users that
are visiting the website
and now there are there are things you
might want to know about these users
like
how many distinct users visited
facebook.com today so the question now
is
how can facebook efficiently or whatever
company efficiently process this stream
using very little memory you need an
algorithm to do that
it's not obvious that there should be a
very low memory algorithm that doesn't
have to remember everything i mean
the most naive algorithm would be
remember every single person who visited
my webpage
but potentially this list could get very
long so i have to store a lot
so that's where streaming comes in the
streaming algorithm
gives them a way of summarizing the data
into a very short synopsis
me and two friends of mine back in 2010
came up with
the first algorithm that is provably
optimal for this problem
i think i was in either seventh or
eighth grade at some point when i was
online
browsing i noticed that if i right
clicked the web page and pressed view
source i could see the source code for
the page which was html
and the next time we went on a trip to
the mainland us
i bought a book on html i self-studied
it brought it back and practiced making
websites
so these are kids who most of them don't
even know what cs is when they start
and they're coming in it's a four week
program 40 hours per week and
they're staying in dorms and we're
training them like all the way from the
beginning
basic introductory programming all the
way to like algorithms
one of the reasons i really enjoy the
program is like watching these kids
and getting to a point where they they
actually understand
in upper division college material and
computer science like algorithms